[Music]
hi everyone my name is Lina Vinod I'm
focused on Twitter and I'm specializing
in marketing community care and project
management in tech I'm a committed to
the open source projects hoody and
apache couchdb and I'm a co-founder and
CEO at the neighborhoodie a software
development and consulting company what
you can see behind me is an acre in
southern Germany close to the village
where I grew up and this is where this
talk begins this acre in southern
Germany this land is cultivated land
this is culture the English term culture
evolved in the mid 15th century and
originally meant the tilling of land it
was about who cared for which parts of
land who did the work on it and who
brought in the harvest there's also a
figurative sense of culture which leads
us to the main case in which we refer to
today our modern term culture is the
expression of the way we act and refers
to a community or group which shares
common experiences that shape the way
its members understand the world I work
in the tech world and I contribute to
open source and I love what I do
because I found amazing people there and
great projects which have become near
and dear to me still the future of
open-source is in danger this is why in
this talk I want us to take a look at
culture in the world of free Libre and
open-source software today and to make
it a bit easier for both you and me
others refer to open source from now on
and even if you're not contributing to
open source projects yourself most of
these topics are applicable to general
tech culture and human interaction in
general today technology wise
open-source is highly relevant mobile
social medium cloud services and big
data for very important
of our time rely heavily in open source
open source is also relevant for
business it contributes 450 billion
euros per year only to the European
economy so things are going great in
open source right let me show you one
thing first the amazing people from
Greek feminism wiki are collecting
sexist incidents in key communities
including technology industry open
source software gaming and more this is
the number of sexist incidents per year
starting in the year 2000
today on September 14 2014 the number of
sexist incidents only this year is 52
although this graphics does not only
display incidents in open-source
software it depicts one thing clearly a
lot of things are going terribly wrong
in our communities and their culture and
here's why often when you talk about
open source projects people quickly
refer to the community and are usually
very excited about it so let's take a
closer look at communities Dianna
Harrelson an anthropologist did
scientific research on the Fedora
project 75% of the respondents to her
questions agreed that they felt that the
Fedora project is a community some
adding answers like the community is the
project and without the community we're
lost but when you're talking about the
community and even if you're
appreciating it there's one essential
point we must not miss Joseph rasa
philosopher phrased it if the culture is
decaying or if it is discriminated
against the options and opportunities
open to its members will shrink
community is not just about building
nice stuff and hanging around with nice
people in chat rooms mailing lists on
conferences like this one today every
troll every sexist comment every
harassment towards just one single
community member will directly harm this
the entire community the product that
you're building and finally open-source
in general its values its ideas and its
existence
one major deterministic of culture is
language most climate orbiter which you
can see in this picture was a robotic
space probe launched by NASA in 1998 to
study the climate atmosphere and surface
changes on Mars this space probe finally
got lost in space it disintegrated due
to atmospheric stresses what was the
reason for this robots test it was
caused by human communication failure
four pieces of software producing and
expecting data in different units to
navigators from the teams involved have
pointed out those issues but their
concerns had been dismissed what
happened to Mars climate orbiter is
briefly described by Conway's law
introduced in 1968 by Melvin Conway a
computer programmer Conway's law states
that organizations which design systems
produce designs which are copies of
their communication structures
open-source carries Conway's law to
extremes as a scientist phrased it in
open-source there's a hybrid ISM of
dialogue and code where the dialogue is
directly embedded in the code they
called open-source a network of people
and things that is constructed through
the materialization of language in other
words all communications in an
open-source project will have direct
impact on the product like the software
that you're building all communications
no matter if there are any if there are
none and it have hit peaceful or violent
I want to show you a part of the
endangered languages project every dot
you can see on this map excerpt stands
for one of over 3,000 languages that are
currently at risk of becoming extinct
language lost is not new and even if a
few of those languages disappeared large
parts of the world population could
still talk so why should we care if
languages are lost
let me ask you two things first who of
you has ever contributed to a free
liberal or open-source project
well it's plenty and who of you is a
programmer or has ever done anything
related to programming lights editing a
bit of HTML or CSS okay huge overlaps I
see that as people who can deal with
programming languages you know that one
of the core functionalities is that
language shapes reality one change in an
expression in the source code of an
application can affect everything and
break everything I guess some of you
have heard of that language is an
essential part of our culture and it
shapes the way we express ourselves and
this is why when one language disappears
into oblivion we are all diminished
thus silencing people and their voice is
an open source these tables and in
dangers each and every one of us we in
open source have to stop silencing
people when they speak out about threats
mobbing sexism and other topics that
show are broken culture open source is
the materialization of language and our
community culture influences every one
of us this is why we have to take even
more care of the culture in open source
communities because the future of open
source will be mainly determined by its
culture let's see what other aspects we
have to care for in our communities and
start this with a short excursion to
biology as Charles Elton and ecologists
argued simple non diverse communities
are more easily upset than richer ones
that is they're more vulnerable in
biology there's a special research field
for this topic and part of it is the so
called stability diversity hypothesis
in short the hypothesis states that the
more diverse a community is the more
stable and productive it is a great
example for space which is diverse by
default are rainforests typically they
possess a great deal of species
diversity around 40 to 75 percent of all
biotic speech
uh native to the rainforests same goes
with Carol coral reefs they occupy less
than 0.1% of the world's ocean surface
that is around the size of France yet
they provide a home for 25% of all
marine species diversity means variety
and dissimilarity it is a state and
process of involving people who are
different from each other into a group
and it aims to create an inclusive
culture diversity is the natural
settings usually nothing we have to
implement or fix diversity is the
default in artificial settings like open
source communities are we have to take
care for diversity ourselves and first
and overall because diversity is just
the right thing to do as various various
studies show diversity also enables us
to solve complex problems better and
faster be more creative and stimulated
through persistent exposure to minority
perspective make better decisions and
generate more innovation this means if a
community is not diverse it's broken
diversity includes age ability ethnicity
socioeconomic class personal background
gender and far more still people do not
fit into single boxes all of us fall
into a variety of dimensions every one
of us has had different life experiences
and perceives the world differently thus
we need to take care as well about the
intersections of these groups let's take
a look at some examples according to the
2013 flaw spawn 89% of contributors to
open source are men 11% of women but
this is not just about a binary gender
system here currently there's so little
space for LGBT IQ people in open source
that there are not even numbers and it's
worst for people who are marginalized
twice so even more like for example
women of color we also need diversity in
ethnicity why people are still forming
the major mass of
an open source and we urgently need to
get people of all ethnicities into our
project we also need to aim for
diversity in skills and get non-coding
people like designers writers people
with organizational skills and many more
on board and we need diversity in ideas
and backgrounds the broader the amount
of ideas backgrounds and experiences in
our communities the further we can go
and we need to aim for more working on
diversity in our communities should be a
daily task for every one of us or to
like phrase it like Aaron Hardwick
recently did on Twitter when everybody
is making technology the technology they
make will be for everybody
community means the appreciation of
diversity and variety community culture
is our daily answer to the question who
which people and what which kind of
contributions are being welcomed and
valued in our open-source projects
they're strong values and goals behind
open-source software development which
are the reason why it exists and it kept
this kept alive some of these values are
for example providing alternatives to
closed source software enabling
independence and driving innovation but
there's one more reason why open source
software is built software in general is
built to perform useful work run a
computer system solve problems offer
solutions make things better and more
but make things better for whom software
is built for people it's built for users
any software exists for being used by
someone
the number of developers in this world
is 18 million people in total that
already includes hobbyists who are just
coding as a hobby and 18 million total
is in comparison to the world population
0.26 percent which means for every
software developer out there there are
399 people who have other professions or
just don't code now let me just give
those 399 people a few more colors to
get them closer to reality and there we
go when we're talking about software we
can't have this conversation without
talking about users software is built
for them and each of those 399 people
have their very own individual needs and
even our software developer themselves
will also be a software user this means
the building software is an act of
representation many of us the people who
are here today are very privileged and
our realities are very far from those of
millions of people on this planet the
users of our software are a very diverse
group and representation means
responsibility as people who work on
software we have this representation
role to act according to and this is why
non diverse communities working on
software can just not be justified only
moving beyond self referential modes can
enable us to develop infrastructure
processes products and work that
resonate with the broader population
misrepresentation leads to serious
issues one of them illustrated here in a
tweet by G Hooda cuts the direct direct
community loves good enough solutions
where good enough means horribly broken
except for my case we already have
representation problems in our community
itself and it's not getting better
outside this community we have to
fulfill our representation roles
properly in our communities so we can
finally enable people to really trust
the software we're building I want to
give you an example which depicts the
trust issue
exposing our users too far too often the
Korea chorus a choir member by a group
in Austin Texas had a Facebook group for
its choirs members the president of his
fire chorus added two members of the
choir to this Facebook group what the
president didn't know Facebook
automatically told all their friends
that they were now members of the queer
chorus Facebook group thing is both
those people had decided to not inform
their friends and families about being
queer it was Facebook that did that for
them but inadvertently exposing this
information to their friends and
families Facebook made a choice instead
of leaving it up to them many more
people have been stung by accidentally
revealing secrets online that were
easier kept in the past we need to keep
examples like this in mind and build
software that respects its users the
topic of proper user representation is
also linked with one of the core values
and goals of open source freedom freedom
is the idea of giving users choices
power and control over the tools they
use it's often stated that users aren't
able to see how the apps they use work
check if they're secure and change them
if they want to so let me ask you
another question and ask you to raise
your hands again who of you has at least
once read the source code of your mail
server that your email provider ranks
for you oh one person kudos so we have
to ask how many people actually can do
this how many people have not only the
interest but also the resources and
knowledge to check the source code of
their software how close to people's
actual realities can this idea of
freedom practically be the idea of long
term freedom for users through open
source is a great goal which we have to
perceive
but we have to take care to not make
this a patronizing idea that forgets
about many people's realities instead we
have to build products that understand
people's needs and thier capabilities
and we have to build them in diverse
communities so we can make this ideal of
freedom a thing that is closer to
people's realities than it is now
another danger we're currently facing is
shown by what happened to the Mayas
although the culture and civilization
were highly developed it declined and
suddenly disappeared around 800 to 900
BC some archaeologists add that the
mayor collapse was merely a collapse of
the ruling elites these theories can't
be proven 100% but the Maya show us that
it's neither change nor technology that
threatened the integrity integrity of a
culture the Maya had enough culture
change and technology but it wasn't that
prospect for threatened them it was
power the crude face of domination if
the needs of individuals in one culture
are continually suppressed social
systems can become unstable one person
in the Fedora project study which I
mentioned before said I used to believe
that this project was a community but it
seems more like a grouping of various
anarchists and monarchists who think
everyone else is like them we really
have to take care to avoid clicks and
deletes which exclude community members
and enforce those unhealthy power
structures which destabilize our
communities we have to stop the
marginalization of people the
worshipping of heroes Bro culture rock
stars code unicorns and people who
cannot be criticized anymore because of
their status thus leads us to two other
core concepts and goals of open source
which are decentralization and democracy
data shows that open source software is
not quite as democratic and
decentralized as it proclaims to be
analysis shows that of 5 billion bytes
of open source code 74% was written by
the most 10% active users democracy and
decentralization open source will both
require diverse communities to enable
more stable democratic democratic
processes and achieving real
decentralization open-source project
often also proudly refer to their
meritocracy the belief that those with
married flow to the top that they should
be given more opportunities and higher
rewards finally and sadly at the same
time the term meritocracy was originally
coined as a negative example for a
system with highly critical approaches
Noah Slater recently described
meritocracy as a sort of meter story
which we repeat to each other and which
we use to construct other stories that
then explain things for example why
people are included or excluded from our
projects meritocracy is often celebrated
as objective whilst the homogeneity of
open-source and various studies show
that it accessor bates the lack of
diversity and institutionalize is
structural inequality this also includes
that we have to find new models to value
contribution when you're thinking about
building the future of open-source we
have to include those who have less
opportunity less time and less money
that would allow them to freely
contribute we need to rethink what is
being valued in open source projects
especially with the needs of
marginalized people in our minds and our
main question should always be who do we
care for do we care for contributors who
contribute or do we care for people this
question is an essential one and a topic
that is near and dear to me people in
our open-source communities experienced
not only good times they experienced bad
Bernard's mental health issues like
depression and much more these are
serious issues which we can't ignore and
some of them are even enforced through
structural inequality meritocracy and
community related issues we as members
of open source communities have to
implement a culture where mental health
issues are not stigmatized where we talk
openly about them and lead an open
discussion about how to avoid people
burning our through open source
contributions we have to implement a
culture in which people are heard and
they know that there are people who care
for them we have to make sure to be
there for the people in our project and
communities not because we want them to
keep contributing but because we care
for the people you know that in our
bodies with arteries and veins both
parts of our circulatory system arteries
are the blood vessels that carry blood
away from the heart
mostly oxygenated blood there's a
special coronary artery which is located
directly at our heart it's job is to
supply blood to the heart muscle and
thus keep it working
still it sometimes happens that there's
plaque building up along the inner walls
of the arteries of the heart
this plaque narrows the arteries it
reduces blood flow to the heart it can
progress without anyone noticing
evidence for it for years and what
happens there is called coronary artery
disease as it progresses it leads to
lack of oxygen in the body cells can
cause chest pain and finally lead to
death an open source our communities are
our hearts they nourish the entire body
our projects without our community's
open source is lost narrowing those
communities by limiting and restricting
their spaces leads to serious problems
for individuals communities the products
we're building and finally in dangers
the future of open source in general
there are already many in this
and individuals in open-source and tech
that are working on improving all those
topics these people and their Elly's are
spending a significant amount of time on
improving the culture we have an open
source today some of them are for
example black girls code at Dryden
LGBTIQ Model View culture trans heck and
many more the least we also do is listen
to them support their work share what
they're saying and transfer this to the
communities we're all in we have to
widen our communities welcome and
appreciate everyone to ensure that our
heart keeps beating and to ensure that
open-source can have a future because
open-source can only have a future if it
does everything to be inclusive thank
you
[Applause]